so did joe biden have the most
disastrous first
month of any president in modern history
joe biden has had the most disastrous
first month of any president
in modern history i mean we all knew the
bite administration was going to be bad
but none of us imagined how bad
we all knew that the biden
administration was going to be bad
but none of us even imagined just how
bad
they would be and how far left they
would go he never talked about this
we would have those wonderful debates he
would never talk about this
we didn't know what the hell he was
talking about so if a republican
president makes a triumphant return to
the white house
i wonder who that will be a republican
president
will make a triumphant return to the
white house
and i wonder who that will be so it was
just like old times at cpac as trump
boiled it down for all of us while you
no longer have his mean tweets keeping
cnn anchors up
at night you also have unsecured borders
fewer jobs a dead pipeline rising gas
prices a return to a disastrous climate
agreement
and rising crime that gets a pass from
the cowards of cancel culture
and the only good thing joe has
the vaccines came from you know who
never let them take the credit because
they don't deserve the credit
they just followed now they're following
our plan
and then he laid down the most vital
challenge would joe on behalf of the
moms and dads and children of america
get the schools open and open them now
on behalf of the moms dads and children
of america i call on joe biden to get
the schools
open and get them open now that's pretty
clear
finally i wonder what we will see for
the next four years
for the next four years the brave
republicans in this room will be at the
heart of the effort to oppose the
radical democrats the fake news media
and their toxic
cancel culture something new to our ears
cancel culture
and i want you to know that i'm going to
continue to fight
right by your side the only division is
between a handful of washington d.c
establishment
political hacks and everybody else all
over the country
but that's not all you're going to see
you will see trump and perhaps
others in the party that will learn from
him trump showed other republicans that
you got to fight fire with fire
and you know that it worked because
suddenly he became an existential threat
that's what happens when you expose the
media trump offered a clear succinct
difference yesterday people say he
ruined a party others say he saved it
it could be both the republicans have
now become a new party
one for the ignored the working classes
the opposite of the elites
time to embrace that as the dems become
no different from its colluders on cnn
those well-dressed dopes controlled by
the woke
so uh jesse uh thank god for trump we
needed something interesting to talk
about he's like a cargo plane
that air dropped cigarettes and
chocolate to board troops in the media
[Laughter]
well i don't smoke but i love chocolate
and there is a lot to chew on gut felt
yeah we could talk the whole hour about
that speech but i'll just say two things
one thing he said that really struck me
he said the republican party is the
party of love
and that's something that rush limbaugh
talked about when he said what defines a
conservative
a conservative is a conservative because
they have such
deep love for the american people love
for the country
love for the constitution and all the
great leaders that made our proud
history
so great so when you love something
you put that thing first and that's all
america first is all about
putting the american people first not
global institutions not other countries
not isms or multinational corporations
it's the average guy and through trade
wage
and immigration policy he created a
middle class boom
that helped everyone all races creeds
and colors
and that's why it's so sad to see joe
biden
rejoin bad deals and tear up good ones
just because he hates trump and his
supporters so much
and it's devastating to watch and it
makes me sad because i'm such
an emotional person the other thing is
this greg and you touched on the vaccine
stuff history is gonna i believe
at least my history will show that
donald trump
saved millions of lives and millions of
jobs joe biden wouldn't have banned
travel from china he would have kept the
economy
shut down longer and he never would have
launched warp speed
at record time so he would have cost
millions more lives and millions more
jobs
so donald trump ordered 200 million
doses of the vaccine
okay half of them have been distributed
right now and
75 million of them have been
administrated
so not a single dose has been injected
to an american
on march 1st ordered by joe biden
all of these doses so far as of today
have been distributed through the
military trump's plan
and administered through the states
trump's plan
joe biden is following trump's plan and
the trajectory of the injections
is just a steady rise he hasn't
supercharged it so i want peter ducey to
ask
jen saki for acknowledgement of that
and to thank you well done uh the the
republican party is the party of love in
the democratic party
the party of lust we'll be right back
dana
you know um what i thought was
interesting is identifying the democrats
as the party of cancel culture
like being anti-free speech or
pro-censorship
i think that's a that's that's a pretty
good strategy do you think it is
well i think i mean look i i think that
the democrats realize that
the general election went their way for
the presidency but
across the board almost everywhere you
look in america that wasn't
the case um state legislatures uh the
congressional offices
obviously uh and the some of the senate
races and so i think that they realize
that
you know they're kind of living on
borrowed time i think that's one of the
reasons they're in such a hurry
to try to get as much done as they
possibly can cancel culture i think is a
part of that do you remember when
president trump in the 2016 election
said
that political correctness was ruining
our country it got a huge applause line
right and
people are are feeling that yeah and so
and and that's not going to end i would
say that
um being respectful of diversity of
thought has to be inclusive
of everyone including even people within
your own party now one thing
he did not do yesterday not saying he's
going to start a third party
that there was speculation about that
and i think that his
um basically description of the
biden team his critique was pretty
effective and if republicans can figure
out a way to unify behind that i think
the biden team would realize that
they've got um a tiger bites tale with
all of these problems coming
to the forefront they're just focused so
much on getting 1.9 trillion dollars in
relief
well relief passed before march 14th
and then they'll try to worry about the
other things but you can already see the
cracks and the foundation of the
democratic unity are absolutely
happening
and whether president trump runs again
who knows we haven't seen this since
grover cleveland
gave it a shot i mean but you know
history can
repeat itself that is true that is true
and it's a good point about
cancer culture is like the frankenstein
monster of political correctness so it
seems like a logical extension for trump
and katie he won the cpac poll handily i
didn't even come in a close second
yeah i didn't see you on the list greg
i'm so sorry um
you know but the cpac is a conservative
political action conference it's a place
where conservatives go every year to get
involved to figure out how they can you
know make a difference when it comes to
forwarding conservative values and i
thought when president trump talked
about fighting against the left and
focusing the energy on that that's
important but also we talked about
the power that republicans do have in
the states to go after big tech to work
on things like censorship
at the local level and then of course he
talked about 2022
and 2024. so he gave people there kind
of an assignment to go out and fight
against the left
remain focused on the things that
they're doing to to not let them rewrite
the history of the trump administration
and of the republican party
and also to fight these things in the
places where they do have some leverage
against these democrats in their states
yeah one i know that you were
up all night saturday like it was the
day before christmas
knowing that that donald trump was gonna
speak
you were just so excited and i think i
heard overheard you say in the green
room it was the greatest speech you ever
heard
well it sure was it sure was like nick
at night it was like a re-run i've heard
that speech before
you know and that speech obviously turns
on a lot of people
i'll say that for it i mean but the big
news out of it to me was
that you know that he still says he won
the election
and is continuing to promote that
fiction even though we know it's so
damaging to the country we all saw the
violence
on the capitol at the capitol hill and
you know and it continues to damage the
republican party and he says now here's
a list of people
in the republican party to go after the
people who told the truth
about not only the election but what
happened on january 6. so
i think he is promoting again you know
more division not only in the country
but in the party and i think that's
really difficult because
you know the obviously people in the
country are worried about more violence
coming that's why we still have the
fencing around the cap
on all that but i think people inside
the republican party are also looking to
try to find a way to go
forward to build the party going forward
and again it's just so difficult
when everything focuses just on one
personality
his comments about biden i found
intriguing because it seemed to me to be
so revealing greg it seemed to me like
he's
jealous it seems to me like he's jealous
about the idea that
biden is having success the covet
infection rate the death rate's going
down uh he's jealous about the idea that
the vaccines are getting out he's
jealous about the idea
that somehow you know the rescue package
has already now passed the house
looks like it's on its way through the
senate successfully by the end of this
week
and i think he's just jealous i mean
it's like it's coming out of his ears
i don't know man i don't know how you
can read uh
somebody's mind and their feelings i
just look at the look at what he's
saying you know the thing too is
it's been three months since the
election the dems the dems questioned an
election for four years
it's weird how you changed the standards
on that but we've we've been over that a
million times